i saw sandra burchai google ceo
said that he likes uh the thing you
mentioned
not the yoga nidra but the the
nsdr not sleep deep breath uh podcast
over
meditation i don't know if you saw that
yeah i saw that yeah yeah yeah uh why
what what do you think that is what do
you think the difference is yeah so
non-sleep deep breath nsdr is an acronym
that i coined because it encompasses a
lot of practices that are not meditation
per se
but that bring the brain and body into a
state of relaxation and focus so
hypnosis is one variant of nsdr there
are other variants of nstr you can just
look these up and you'll find them and i
think that they've caught on and that
the
google
the ceo of google uh is an avid
practitioner of nsdr
because it has this amazing ability to
reset your energy levels and focus
whereas with meditation many people find
meditation hard and part of the reason
they find it hard is that it requires
focus nsdr is a state which is very
calm and relaxing you don't have to work
too hard you're just listening to a
script whereas most forms of meditation
not all but most forms of meditation
involve cranking up the activity in your
prefrontal cortex
and
trying to see your thoughts as opposed
to thinking your thoughts or um focus on
your breath but then third personing
yourself in some respect and that's work
and so many people who meditate quite
intensely feel more exhausted now that
doesn't mean that meditation doesn't
have any utility but it's distinctly
different than nsdr and i think that
people are working certainly the ceo of
google have to imagine working very hard
and using his forebrain if he's gonna
have 20 or 30 minutes to take a break
he should and i think this is what he's
doing he should go out for a jog and not
listen to anything and just kind of let
his mind wander or sit there in a chair
and just zone out or do nsdr the problem
is people are not that good at shifting
states
we are all actually pretty good at even
people with severe adhd
in an episode about this
can become hyper focused on things that
they actually enjoy
because dope and most of the drugs
designed to treat adhd are drugs that
increase the levels of dopamine so when
you like something there's dopamine
release and you can focus it's when you
don't like something that's hard to
focus shifting states is hard i'm sure
you've experienced this if you've ever
been in deep research or podcasting
podcasting and then all of a sudden you
go for a run you probably spend the
first third of that run thinking and
then in the middle 30 you're kind of
that thinking is is fractured a bit and
then in the final third is where you
finally get to relax because the brain
doesn't shift states very quickly we can
go from sleep to wakefulness quickly we
can go from wakefulness to sleep quickly
but we don't shift between different
states of consciousness like a step
function
except in rare cases right fear is one
all of a sudden we hear an explosion
right now it's a step function we're in
fear or we're in alertness right um a
heightened state of alertness but nsdr
is terrific at allowing people to learn
to shift their state and i actually
would venture to argue that
part of the value of meditation and
exercise is the actual state that you
get into in deep meditation or exercise
but just as valuable is the transition
that you have to take yourself through
from one state of mind to the other and
then back again i when i look you know
david goggins he always seems to come up
but he re because he represents so many
important things drive determination
override of emotional state
going from being a 300 pound plus person
to a fit person through he's never
revealed anything
substantial about what he ate or what he
didn't he basically says like listen run
a lot eat less right um
but what's remarkable is
so much of what he says is about those
transitions about taking oneself from a
state of i don't want to to
scruffing oneself like you're going to
do it anyway and then being able to
carry that into into regular life so to
speak so i think that um
nsdr is immensely powerful it's zero
cost and one of the reasons i'm such a
fan of people doing it is that most
people don't stick to a meditation
practice
there are also been a few cases you
might find this interesting there's a
book by scott carney i forget what it's
called i think it's called the
transcendence trap or something i'm
going to have that title wrong but
there have been a fair number of cases
of people that go and do very extensive
meditation silent meditation retreats
who then return to normal life and end
up killing themselves there are states
of mind inside of extended meditations
or silent meditations that are very
beneficial and i'm certainly not
suggesting people don't meditate but i
know at least one person who came back
from one of these long extended
meditation retreats and wasn't able to
shift their state back into one that was
functional in regular life and that book
includes a very dramatic story i don't
want to give it away in case people um
check out the book but scott told the
story to me directly once
where
feels they've reached enlightenment
and then commits suicide
so these very unusual brain states are
are potentially hazardous if people
can't return from them
so it's nice to focus not on those
brains states but instead on the
shifting right i do this morning i woke
up a little bit earlier than i would
have liked i use this reverie app that's
research backed rev ri.com there's a
free version of it and or you can try it
for free so i feel that's right hypnosis
for hypnosis and i do a self-hypnosis
to put me back into sleep and if i can't
sleep just put me into a state of deep
relaxation i would i would put um
hypnosis under the category of nsdr yoga
nidra under the category of nstr there
are now some nsdr scripts online if you
just go to youtube that are you can just
listen to and do you like those i do
yeah i think the one from made4 is quite
good i have an affiliation with them but
it's free so i feel comfortable
mentioning it i do i i really like the
reverie app um i can very and as you the
more you do them the more quickly you
can shift your brain into a state of
deep relaxation i will sometimes stop
mid podcast if it's sometimes our
recordings go seven eight hours and i'll
stop and i'll do a one minute hypnosis
they have one minute hypnosis inside
reverie you're only going to you're only
going to find that one minute hypnosis
is effective if you are routinely doing
10 and 15 minute hypnosis
in addition to that meaning i do it
every other day or so 10 or 15 so
there's a is there a youtube uh one
minute hypnosis or is this there are but
inside of reverie as well you can find
them online a really good pull it up
sorry please um yeah so reverie is good
and then michael seeley s-e-a-l-e-y
he has some long hypnosis scripts but
again these are all free and
you know there's a lot of good research
now on the neural networks and it shifts
your so-called default network default
mode network it shifts how much of your
forebrain you're using and it also is
very very good if you i get so many
questions about
hey i'm really upset i found out about
my girlfriend's sexual past or hey i'm
so upset i found out that my boyfriend
was cheating or oh so and so died how do
i get over these emotions how do i deal
with them and hypnosis has shown to be
very useful for people to learn to bring
themselves into a state of deep
relaxation to literally
project in their mind's eye
these very intense things that they
don't like
and then for people to associate with
other emotions in their body to learn to
be calm while feeling your feelings
to dissociate the mind body
communication to some extent just
observe the feelings observe them and
start to associate them with positive
experiences you're an android guy so
soon it should be available on android
and then it doesn't exist for me yeah i
know
uh you know i don't get android is the
device of the people all you elitist
people with your iphone but tell me this
about android now now you want to this
is the one thing that gets me yeah
because i'm very close to someone who
uses an android phone i feel like that
so you you have great people in your
life that's good to know no their
messages always look green to me but i
answer yours not despite that um but
they
i feel like the android phones are very
trigger happy like anything i touch does
something whereas the apple phone is
kind of built for like a macaque monkey
to be able to operate which is great for
me because i'm more of a macaque monkey
and you're a more sophisticated ape oh i
see i see it like i think like you have
to be they're more sensitive yeah you
have to have you know i mean i've got
fat fingers you know i've got clumsy
fingers yeah yeah the android is is too
well maybe you need to soften your touch
what i would do is go into the most sort
by most popular
um because there's some older ones that
i really like and it generally scales
with that so i'll do the um
this one the hypnosis for clearing
subconscious
negativity that's an hour-long one the
sleep and anxiety one 40 minutes but
those you listen to as you fall asleep
as you fall asleep but we're going to do
this now yeah let's listen to it
and i have created this hypnosis
recording for you
to help you and this is the voice how
often does the voice pop up
and at the same time you don't watch it
you just listen to your anxiety
now one of the most important things
of any self-hypnosis experience is to
know and understand
hypnosis people really should know that
stage hypnosis
is about the hypnotist getting you to do
things you wouldn't normally do
self-hypnosis which is what we're
talking about here reverie in this is
about
you getting your brain into the state
that you want
and um again i mean there's a ton of
neuroimaging data and work on trauma and
pain relief and our labs are working on
this with david spiegel's lab i i really
encourage people to explore nsdr and if
this feels a little too wacky and out
there then i would just put in nsdr
into youtube and there's some good nstr
scripts yes that's by the way uh sanders
is a fan of your podcast no that's okay
we don't need to play yeah so i don't
know him and um uh but i was yeah a lot
of uh media outlets picked up on his
love of nsdr and i have to imagine
running google involves a lot of
juggling a lot of he's one of the great
ceos because everybody loves them
everybody loves them have you
interviewed him no but we'll we'll do
the interview eventually so is this
annoying thing about
me being a stickler for three hours
ceos don't seem to understand like not
understand but it's scheduling so what
happens is saunders said yes definitely
let's do it i'm a fan of podcasts as a
fan of yours
and and and then it goes to
his executive assistant like oh let's
find a slot and then they immediately
think all right well one hour it's good
45 minutes 90 minutes by zoom 90 minutes
yeah right well no they know in person
i'm sticking on that but like it's like
no we need more
and it's so hard to to
do you still travel to do your podcast
or generally no most people come down
here most people uh but for certain
situations obviously um like if you're
in prison
right
or you're ahead of me if you get out on
work for a lot of people have anklets so
that they can go to the lex friedman
podcast it probably happened have you
ever been in a prison
no
you know uh either a visitation or on
the inside from my hike i can see san
quentin it's really weird that san
quentin and alcatraz you know bay area
beautiful everyone thinks you know like
there's the bay and there's
alcatraz and san quentin sitting right
there does that make you feel um
you know it's amazing how easy it is to
overlook that they're there and forget
that they're there but when i drive by
san quentin i think about it um i also
think about the people who are in there
who might be innocent
i've seen some of those episodes on
rogan and elsewhere and
amanda knox talks a lot about this right
whether or not you believe her story or
not i happen to believe her story uh
personally based on what i know um
you know i'm sure there are people
disagree with me i think to myself what
it must be like to be in a cell
and know in your heart's heart you
didn't do it
you know i mean i can't think of
i can't think of many things worse
i can't think of many things worse
you